te souviens-tu on avait entendu des
bobards dans un salon de coiffure à
l'époque
tiens je rêverais de faire ça et devoir
d'être des poils aussi l'on tombé de mon
visage
aujourd'hui on veut devenir barbier
professionnels et ouvrir notre propre
salon bienvenue sur treiber tycoon
n'était pas d'un simulateur de mecs qui
triment avec la musique c'est le faisais
car avant ce vide c'est un petit jeu en
pixel art on ne fait pas souvent et
pourtant c'est très très cool c'est
parti je découvre ça avec vous j'espère
qu'on va être plus fort que quand on
avait dû gérer des call girls là dans
une hip-hop gamme studio au moins de
1300 on est endetté jusqu'à la mort
j'avais pas vu on est morts cliquer sur
un client pour t'occuper de sa barbe
c'est parti j'ai choisi lui il veut de
marbre comme ça du coup à mais c'est
chaud au fait vous raconter les cases à
fond merde mais hadji coupe à bout de
l'as tâche mus par ben spies passe par
moi je les fais un peu en décalé à fin
juin mais je m'en bats les couilles
franchement démerde toi
[Musique]
un génie qu'est la game je vais tout
fait de travers au maire mais voulais un
truc surcôte mec c'est impossible de
faire ça c'est bon mais tu sais quoi
on va juste faire un bout que je
t'épargne et on va te latin en bleu
amelia ciseaux [ __ ] moi j'ai vu tout
fait à la tondeuse pour ça je me suis
foiré ok on lui fait bien bleu c'est
parti là qui fait oui nous a payé il a
kiffé [ __ ] le pot alors les
distractions attirent les consommateurs
cliquer sur le pc pour en acheter bas
hockey question peut acheter quoi un
porte manteau ça attire les gens une
plante une plante sur les mecs ont
débarrassé les [ __ ] hipster et les
pisteurs s'adorent quoi ça dans les
plantes boom
voilà m juste là pour apaiser ses pieds
dessus comme ça que je toucherai sa
barbe comme ça il gardera bien les pieds
sur terre vous ai compris que je ne
bosse est excellent et un déluge de
pluie 200 $ de texte mais c'est abusé
mais qu'est ce que tu veux oh oui ça
c'est super simple hier prouser tous des
barbes de huit mois mais sans déconner
ce que je suis en train de lui faire mon
gars je m'engage sur une faille or
regardez regardez comme je suis
perfectionniste sas a fait la réputation
du salon ça je vais fait pile ce qu'ils
voulaient mon gars non c'est vous voyez
juste un petit carré là un petit carré
là oh lala lala com me donne quoi il m'a
rien donné non mais là je vais fermer
déjà mais à mes yeux me dutin la barre
2d ça wervicq il fait un avc quoi
[Musique]
game over the survécu trois minutes
superbe on a cette fois mais qu'on perd
pas tant on rase plus de poils que dans
sa [ __ ] j'ai tendance à dire ma vanne
et je les oublie y était encore jamais
arrivé
alors je vais acheter une fourniture va
acheter une plainte qu un matelas bien
là toi ok il veut quoi oh [ __ ] un truc
bien relou mais je vais lui faire ça en
2 2 voilà ça c'est fait alors elle vole
mexes n'importe quoi il faut arrêter ok
tu la veux quoi une sorte de ver un peu
clair comme ça la voile avec 232 $ il a
quitté mon pote toi bien là où il veut
le truc chiant mais je m'en bats les
couilles
on va y aller au feeling est bon dit que
sa mère nick sa grosse mer voilà
franchement ce que tu as c'est vraiment
génial
il m'a donné soit 36 dollars celle de la
plus value à graver plus même toi bien
là quoi mais qui fait ça mais qui fait
ça mais qui fait ça mais avec son et
connaissez un sketch beau temps mais
c'est comme ça je me suis fort et
franchement mec j'ai failli réussir non
je te jure du coup j'étais un petit peu
indulgente est cool a par contre
beaucoup là on est vraiment et b mais
184 dollars on peut engager un barbier
on n'a pas assez de salles quoi ces
coûts de combien d'agrandir sa salle de
1000 $ [ __ ]
voilà ta qui fêtait camair jumelles
épate par absa foule à moi sans cadeau
là ça fait plaisir ça j'ai dû le payer
car avant ce recul et je le déteste
prochaine fois je refuse dire avec toi
tu veux ça mais franchement c'est moche
on va se contenter d'une petite
moustache c'est très très bien mais que
c'est pas beaucoup mieux comme ça on n'a
jamais fait un spectacle en arcosm
voilà c'est stylé voilà 120 dollars la
chaîne
mais pourquoi c'est quoi ça c'est la
nouvelle mode ça obtient lui je lui ai
bien fait vous avez hop je te laisse un
quart de poil sur le pull c'est la
nouvelle mode qui remplace la mode des
pin's finalement c'est le même effet je
tâche sûreté dire que tu vas pécho 09
allez c'est parti 136 dollars hu ont
lors des modes mais mais je paie de plus
en plus il gagne de moins en moins je me
plains beaucoup je suis désolé je me
plains plus que ta maman quand elles
rentrent du travail c'est quand même te
dire c'est au pays quand je parle de
votre maman comme ça de manière positive
ou pas moi ça me plait énormément je
peux pas engager je peux rien faire je
suis comme un coup on peut pas augmenter
les prix y'a pas un truc augmenter les
prix et ben mec je me ruine j'achète une
table beau temps à la mecque faut qu'on
enchaîne on va perdre voilà c'est très
bien et le petit trou palau [ __ ] tu as
fait un truc vraiment stylé bong avec
celle de bart a pas besoin de cash
oreilles c'est davantage c'est parti
c'est gratuit bîmes 200 dollars bon
alors dans chaque caisse tu veux mon
gars c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
ce que je t'ai fait fais moi confiance
n'est pas le barbier numéro un du
quartier pour rien à plat plus en amont
[ __ ] ça va super vite tout ce qui se
passe ah ça c'est bien
bien ouf la quête tout ça faut vraiment
qu'un jour je vais utiliser le système
finalement parce que là je m'en bats les
couilles et sa machine donne d'études
moi j'ai pas peur des fans donnent et
une à l'envoyer le ciseau ce parti a
c'est super chiant ça c'est super chiant
équipe mais c'est moi on lui a fait un
truc incroyable ce mec à la crise -
nicox a pris dans l'oural ont écouté et
ol c'est une coupe que j'ai appelé la
barre fixe pourquoi la barre fixe parce
que j'aime bien spéciale accroché et
faire des soleils voilà il a atterri il
a dix sur dix par le jury c'est super
seb a été trop longue mais tu vas payer
256 dollars pour la marque xbox d'impro
tripes ce jeu-là bon nouvèl propal le
collier en perles de ta maman sous forme
de barbe c'est lui fera plaisir elle se
verra à travers toi merger x 280 $ pour
ça allait mais qui n'ont pas la valeur
des choses même pour une coupe de
malades 214 heures doit tuer par balles
et six au hockey je compris est coupable
mais what the fuck est en ciseaux il ya
un problème mais cas et décès dégage
donne 104 dollars voilà pigeon je m'en
bats les couilles toi tu veux la barbe à
cyprien il n'y a pas de soucis bah oui
200 vidéos la [ __ ] et la moto d'un jean
kissi prix en plus cités subir abonne
toi j'ai tenté l'escroquerie s'est pas
fait avoir le courage lui l'abonné à 30
minutes consommateurs c'est sûr à
attache pas mixer le nom de deux
associations c'est un centre dollars
dans une minute sable avec sa mort c'est
fini c'est fini ça j'aime bien les clubs
comme ça ça c'est le mec qui font vive
et salon de barbier hop hop hop voilà
aux stars fout là voilà osef on dirait
une game de tetris c'est barbe aux plats
pardon mais c'étaient ses excuses
j'avais des amis dans mes notes parce
que je trouve qu'on avait toutes les
blagues et les vannes possible voilà des
sujets trop dur j'aimerais avoir un
emploi au gpra notre attention attention
à mr fois j'étais une chambre avant
c'est vrai c'est que ça coûte 2000
dollars
aussi attentes autant j'aimerais
recommencer ça se trouve quand tu fais
une coupe à la perfection et fils genre
5000 dollars d'un coup on va essayer le
ciseau ils marchent pas et coupe rien
habana sa coupe d'un coup et pourquoi
des fois il coupait défaut ils coupent
pas ça que son bras pas bon mec je te
fais un nouveau style m'en bats les
couilles tu refuses les conseils d'un
pro tu es con voilà 48 dollars voilà non
mais plus compliqué quoi le mec qui veut
que je fasse une barbe oméga d'adressé
juge l'a atteint il donne la thune
peut-être enfin on va faire que des
teintures à n'ont clairement pas au
québec lui on lui fait à la perfection
ce parti
[Musique]
à toi mec là on a fait un truc de ouf un
temps là c'est abusé la ressemblance 76
dollar
vous aidez mauvais soit monsieur faisait
de mauvaise foi bon je vis avec un style
honduras miley qui dans sa [ __ ] de
barbe les super ce barbier voilà est
passé sur cette excellente blague de
merde que cette vidéo sa chaîne spike
jonze a pu ces cas n'hésitez pas à aller
mais comme d'habitude franchement séméga
dur julien c'est plus dur que dax où ce
jeu que [ __ ] moi je pense est coupé
des barres de faire carrière dans un une
branche viril delà de la démocratie
finalement éléments retrouve là sur la
touche 1
du coup je vais faire ce que tous les
cas ce sont quoi et youtube heures à
lire si vous regardez la vie dans son
très vite en une prochaine portez vous
bien vous et votre barbe soyeuse et
douches show la démocratie pis
[Musique]